i lived in germany for three months and  here are three things i learned about  german culture people in germany are on  time to everything in america if you  throw a party at seven then people might  come at like 7 30. in germany if you  throw a party at seven they'll show up  at 6 55. number two germans know how to  party when i was in germany there was a  party that the town threw and everyone  went to the party old people young  people and literally you went to bed  when the sun came out came out a lot  earlier there like four or five but that  was like a normal every weekend thing  three german kids get a break for lunch  so while americans eat their lunch in  school german kids were allowed to go  home comment a fun fact about germany